[Music]
would dropping nukes on Mars make it
easier to live there
if we nuked
Duke believe it or not this is something
scientists have considered for decades
Elon Musk of SpaceX seems to think that
nuking Mars might be one of the best and
quickest options to make it a place
where humans could live
the idea is that we would explode
thermonuclear bombs in the sky over the
planet's two poles
this would heat up the ice caps and
release carbon dioxide and water from
the poles
then the greenhouse effect would take
place it would heat up the whole planet
making the surface more habitable
so this all sounds super quick and easy
why haven't we done this yet
it's because there's a high chance that
nuking Mars might not work out the way
we want it to